I want to talk about this oh you might
have to cut it out you played baddie
his name's bad I talk about something
that we might have to cut out yeah go
ahead
Christian Slater's in it but no big deal
who's that oh yeah we don't know you
know back in the circus days now go to
our spots Riggs Wallace David do you
have a rich wall I'm just saying though
like the hairy face person you they had
that condition with the hair right
nowadays you couldn't go a hairy face
right you'd have to call them some sort
of like PC name like facially you know
[Laughter]
[Music]
my name is John like this right he had
dreadlocks
but that's friend
yeah these I think the word dreadlock
what I'm saying yeah I want to know
though yeah okay okay but what I'm
saying is is that we become so PC that
you can't even call some people what
they were comfortable already allows the
worst monologue of the day
that was all the too much better oh let
me stand back in the day man well we had
circuses do right right for the heavy
fast pace guy Yeah right and facially
facially right in the missions yeah
that's good it's pretty good it's better
yeah better thank you thank you so much
you make that candy so unappetizing why
it's the way you go at it
[Music]